ladies and gentlemen welcome everyone to
our first talk here today in the bar
room uh regarding Bridging the Gap
between
traditional uh machine learning using
psyched learn and the rapidly evolving
world of AI with hugging face and Scorch
I'm your on renhard today and I'm here
to introduce our first talker Benjamin
bosen Benjamin is a machine learning
developer at hugging face and maintainer
of the package Scorch um let's welcome
him with a warm Round of Applause uh I
hope you enjoy today's talk and please
keep your questions for the last five
minutes Benjamin the FL is
yours yeah thank you a lot for the
introduction and yeah so many people
here I'm very grateful so if you think
this is yours is talk you're wrong it's
up there but I guess now you're stuck
with me so yeah today I'm going to talk
about how you can extend your psychic
learn workflow with hugging face and
Scorch and
uh yeah it's going to be tough to bring
this in 25 minutes but I'll do my best
and then we have five minutes of
questions at the end
hopefully so if you're in this room I
assume that you all know psyched learn
it's the Bedrock of machine learning in
Python and it really has almost
everything I'd say that you need so lots
of models uh cross validation metric Vis
visualizations so
really um if you're using anything
related to machine learning you should
be using psyched learn but it's missing
a little bit on the side of deep
learning and neural Nets and if that's
something that you're interested in
using with your psyched learn workflow
then you're in the right
talk and to to get to our goal we need a
few ingredients so the first one is
Scorch so I'm one of the maintainers of
scorch we have another one sitting there
and and it's a quite old package uh by
today's standards in machine learning so
it was released like half a year after
pytorch was released and we build it
because we were scratching our own uh
scratching our own itch because uh we
wanted to use pytorch but with a psyched
learn API and this is what Scorch
provides it's really built on py Torch
so it doesn't have multiple backends
like
tensorflow but um it's uh yeah still
very versatile so you can check out the
examples and the docs if you're
interested in learning
more and here on this slide I have a
little bit of a diagram of how Scorch
integrates with the bigger ecosystem so
I know it's quite a lot you don't have
to learn it it's not going to be on a
test but um to get a like a broad
overview like on the outside we have
psyched learn and that works with the
Scorch classes like new new net
classifier or new net regressor so you
can just drop it in if you have a K&N
classifier or a linear regressor you can
just swap it out basically it should
work and then we have different
components inside of scorch which
connect to the uh bigger ecosystem like
hugging phase pie torch and other
libraries
outside
and uh yeah today we're going to focus
on the hugging phase side so what is
hugging phase oh sorry a little bit of
code first so this is how it looks like
when you try to use Scorch without
hugging face first so here we import a
new net classifier so let's assume we
have a classification task and um then
we Define our module so if you have
worked a little bit with pyd you already
know how that works you subass the nn.
module then you write your code and you
can just use basically any code here
that works with pytorch so Scorch
doesn't make a lot of s assumptions and
then you pass it into the neural net
classifier here so can you see the
cursor yeah and um then you can pass uh
the module a couple of hyper parameters
so like the number of epoch and the
learning rate and at the end um you can
also modify the training a little bit
with callbacks so here we're using Epoch
scoring which just means that at the end
of the epoch we calculate the score and
for example if you look at this argument
scoring equals Rock AU
you will probably be familiar with that
because the same argument in pyed learn
when you do scoring pyed learn you can
also pass like scoring argument like
this and the reason is that we are using
py learn under the hood so the metric is
calculated exactly as you would expect
and then at the end of course we can
just call net. fit net. predict net.
predict proper so like you would with
your normal cycled learn classifier and
predict and predict prob will also
return nonp arrays so exactly as you
would expect from Psych
learn okay now we get to a hugging pH so
probably most of you have at least heard
of it maybe used some parts of it but I
don't think that there's anyone in the
world who has used everything from
hugging face because really gotten quite
big and um yeah we will look at some
parts of it today but I really couldn't
cover all of it so there's going to be a
few slides and the backups so if you're
really interested in learning more then
you can later check out the slides and
look at what More Hugging phe has to
offer and so today we're going to focus
on those parts so Transformers and
tokenizers which is probably the biggest
one we will look at parameter efficient
fine-tuning which is something that has
emerged in the last few months um as
something really important with big
models we will look at accelerate which
will help us train our models faster and
then we will have a section on large
language models and by the way the
slides are all online I'll post the link
later so you don't have to take any
notes or
photos um okay so Transformers and
tokenizers what's what's that so
Transformers is probably the most
well-known hugging face uh package and
it implements a lot of Transformers
based pre-trained models so something
like bird GPT Falcon llama and so on and
if there's something new coming out this
week probably next week it's going to be
in Transformer so you really have a very
big choice of Open Source models and
that also implements non Transformer
stuff so it's not really just
Transformers anymore but this is what
people are using it for mainly and then
there's also the hugging phase
tokenizers package which if you're
working with text you have to tokenize
it first and this is what tokenizers is
for so it really implements a lot of
different techniques by PR coding word
piece sentence piece and so on but also
like the padding trun a so everything
that you need to toonize your
text and now let's take a look at how we
can implement it in our pych learn
workflow so first of all we uh import
the auto model for sequence
classification because we assume here
that we want to do a text classification
uh
task and then we will write our pyd
module as I mentioned earlier and this's
a very light wrapper around the auto
model so let's look at what we need we
have an init which takes two arguments
the name which is going to be the name
of the model and the N labels and this
is going to be the number of classes so
psych Le calls it classes here it's
labels and we will just load the
pre-trained model here and pass the
arguments so nothing really happening
there and um for the forward we would
just call the model and return the
logits so it's a really light wrapper
around uh
huging face
Transformers and then as a next piece as
I mentioned we need the tokenizer so
from Scorch we can import the hugging
phase pre-rain tokenizer and this works
as a pyed learn Transformer so you can
call fit and transform on it and most
notably we can put it inside a psyched
learn pipeline so this is just a normal
psyched learn Pipeline with the first
step being the tokenization second step
is our new net classifier which takes
the module that we just
defined and um something to be aware of
if you remember we have those two
arguments name and N labels so how do we
get this to our module well we use the
argument module double underscore name
and module double underscore num labels
and if you know a little bit of psyched
learn you know this double underscore
notation which just means like forward
this argument to this part so here we
are forwarding the name to the module so
that's how how the module knows its
arguments and also something to be aware
of here we are using the model dis still
bir base uncased which is like a smaller
Brad model and the model name is going
to be the same here for the tokenizer
and for the pyos module itself so that
the two fit together because if they
don't then you will get incorrect
results and the rest should be pretty
straightforward if you know a little bit
of psyched learn so you can just call
hit on the pipeline we pass our data so
that would be text here and in the Y we
have our
labels and then Scorch will internally
do a train validation split of your data
of course you can disable that and then
during a training at the end of each
Epoch we will see a little bit of
progress so you can see the train and
validation loss you can see the accuracy
on the validation data set and the time
that it took to calculate all of that
and then once we are finished with the
training we can just call predict and
calculate the accuracy using pyed
learn so yeah that's basically in a very
short time how you can use Transformers
and tokenizers in your pyed learn
workflow and of course if you're using
cycle learn you might also want to do
something like grid search and that's
also possible so if we go going back to
slides we can see that in our pipeline
Second Step was called net so we can use
this name to address the parameters that
we want to grid search on so for example
here for the net D module dander name we
can pass different modules like we can
try this T Bird but we can also use
another Bird model and of course we can
also change the other hyperparameters
like the optimizer the learning rate and
the number of epoch and then we just put
it all into a cycle learn grid search
and it will try out all the different
parameter values so at the end you know
which ones are best for your use
case and here in the slides I have a
bunch of links if you want to know more
if you want to see complete examples and
notebooks and run it for yourself you
can just uh look at those slides later
and um for example there's also a
notebook for vision Transformer models
so it's not only for text you can also
use it for other modalities so um really
recommended to take a look
then next in line I want to talk a
little bit about parameter efficient
fine-tuning so what's that um so there's
this Library called PFT from marking
face and it implements a couple of
techniques that help you work with
really large models so we are talking of
billions of parameters and if you want
to find youe the model so like we did
previously with the bird model but it's
really large that can be a problem so it
will take a lot of memory it be will be
very Freckle so maybe you want to have a
better technique and that is where PFT
comes in so some of the techniques in
PFT are like specialized for uh language
models so we're not going to look at
those today but there are other
techniques like Laura which is short for
low rank adaptations which work with
basically any kind of model so we're
going to uh see how we can use that so
for this problem let's just imagine we
have a very simple Model A multi-layer
perceptron with a hidden input layer
hidden layer output layer and um we want
to apply parameter efficient fine tuning
on this model how can we do that so we
will import PFT and since we want to use
Lura we will first create a Laura config
which is like the specification of how
we want to use it and there we have a
couple of arguments so R is the rank
which basically basically tells you like
how compressed this those extra
parameters are going to be we will also
say which uh layers of our MLP we want
to Target so zero was the input layer
and then two was the hidden layer and
then we also Define the modules to save
so those layers are like trained
normally without any uh adapters applied
on top so that's often recommended for
the classification head if you're on a
classification askk and once we have the
config we just pass it to the G path
model function with the MLP and what we
get at the end is yet again a pych
module so we can put it into the new net
classifier and fit it and it will just
work and by the way in this case we will
only train 1.4% of all the parameters of
the model so the rest is frozen and this
is why it's efficient because we don't
have to calculate the gradients on all
of those parameters we only train it
small part of the whole model and if
you're working with large language
models it's like if you don't have a
giant cluster it's almost a necessity to
use some of those
techniques um also interesting maybe if
you want to just save those 1.4% of the
parameters that were trained and not the
whole thing which can be quite large you
can also do it by calling the safe
pre-train method and then you can see
that this adapter that's how it's called
is like only 1% of the size of the full
model so it also makes it much easier
for you to share your fine H model with
others and as always a couple of links
if you want to learn a little bit more
especially quantization is also getting
very important recently so that's also
supported next let's look at hugging
face accelerate so this is a library
which makes training faster also can be
used for inference but mostly for
training and there are a couple of ways
that you can achieve it so one is very
straightforward is a parallelism so if
you want to use for example distributed
data parallel from py torch it's going
to be much easier if you use it with
accelerate but there are also other
techniques implemented there and here
for this example we want to look at
something which is called mix Precision
training so usually all your weights and
data is in uh float 32 but that's it's
not always necessary so we can go down
to lower precision and get very similar
results but be much faster so let's
check out how we can do that so first of
all we need something from Scorch which
is the accelerate mix in so it's just a
mixing class that you can combine with
any neural net class from Scorch and
then it will basically add the
capabilities to use uh accelerate on top
and then we use the accelerator class
from accelerate and and instantiate it
with the argument mix Precision equals
fp16 so that means we want to use
floating Point 16 Precision for our
model and then the rest is just as you
always do so just initialize the net
pass your custom module and when you
call fit under the hood everything will
be taken care of so that you're using
fp16 so that would will mean that it's
going to be much faster to train your
model and take less
memory
and there's much more that you can do
there but this was just one example and
as always check out the links if you're
interested in
more and finally something that I want
to talk about is something that we added
recently to Scorch which is support for
large language models as zero or F sh
classifiers so what's the deal with that
um You probably all heard about the back
than gpt3 release that you can use these
kinds of large language models as few
short Learners or zero short
Learners
and um something specific would be for
classification so you can put in a text
maybe it's going to be a review of a
product and you want to know whether
it's positive or negative then probably
you don't need to train a model at all
to determine that because a large
language model can answer that question
for you and
if you want to do this kind of work in a
more systematic way I recommend to take
a look at the zero short classifier and
few short classifier that we have in
Scorch and those use hugging face
Transformers under the hood and I will
show you how it looks
like so here we have a zero shot
classifier so let's assume we have some
data and we want to instantiate the
classifier using the hugging face model
big signs blooms so we just pass the
name of the model and then something
interesting happens so during the fit
call we don't pass any data because we
don't need it it's zero shot we don't
need any data here the only thing that
we need to pass is uh the labels so for
example for the sentiment analysis would
be negative and positive so that the
model knows which labels it should
predict and then during the fit call no
fitting happens it just loads the model
that that's it and of course you can use
um predict to get the labels spe that
the model predicts for your data and
also interestingly you can use predict
prober so you will also get back the
probabilities of the model and that's
maybe a bit surprising if you worked
with large language models because
usually you just get the generated
tokens but we found a way also to get
you the probabilities of those
tokens and of course you can customize
so for example if you think the default
prompt that we are using doesn't fit
your task very well you can Define your
own prompt so here we have just one big
string it has two placeholders the
labels and the text so labels would be
positive and negative and then the text
would be the review that you want to
classify and then we just use the prompt
here with the same model and then we can
predict the labels based on that
prompt and of course we can also do a
grid search so um let's assume you have
a couple of prompts that you want to
test maybe a couple of different models
so like blooms gpt2 or Falcon you uh can
do a good search on top of that you can
define a couple of metrics that we're
interested in and then just pass it to
griter CV from psyed learn and it will
do a systematic study of which language
model which prompt works best for your
task and then there's also a f short
learning so that means that we take a
couple of examples and demonstrate to
the language model what it should
predict for those examples so here in
this case we do have to have some
training data so we have to split it
first and then we pass the training data
during the fit call but the training
data can be quite small so here in this
example we only have five samples so we
will take five examples from the
training data and augment The Prompt
with those examples and then um
basically the rest is the same as with
the zero shot classifier and then at the
end we can again call predict and
calculate the accuracy of the F shot
classifier so maybe you're asking
yourself why you should be using that so
first of all again it's a psyched learn
classifier so you can just swap it out
see if it works for you or or if it
doesn't and one nice thing is that it
forces the model to Output the labels
that you gave it to the model so as you
know llms can like steer off on the
wrong path and predict something very
unexpected sometimes so there's no
danger of this happening here and as I
already mentioned you get probabilities
which is also not something that you
usually get we have also implemented
some caching for decoder only
architectures to make it a bit faster
and of course since it's using hugging
face Transformers you have access to all
of those models so um you have a wide
choice for your use case and that
especially important if you have maybe
some data that's sensitive or so and you
don't don't want to send it out to
hugging to open AI API or anything like
that it will all work
locally so um if you have only very few
labeled samples or if you're
bootstrapping your task then maybe you
can think about using the uh zero shot
classifier or fhot classifier also if
you already know you want to use an nlm
just want to study it systematically it
would also be a good fit and we also
added a few things that help you
debugging bad
outputs and for some domains llms are
also very good especially if it requires
very deep understanding of the
sentences on the other hand if you want
to have something that's very fast you
should not use llms they are just too
slow for that um also if you have a
bunch of labeled data probably just use
a normal psyched learn model that
supervised it will work better and if
the task is really simple maybe
something like back of Words which just
be more efficient for
you okay then some links and let's wrap
this
up so today we learned how we can use
Scorch to help bridge the gap between
pyed learn and the hugging face
ecosystem there's a lot more that I
wanted to talk about but I didn't have
time so check out the backup slides of
this talk so like Vision models you can
customize your tokenizer in Grid search
the best hyper parameters for them you
can use the hugging face Hub to store
checkpoints you can use safe tensors
which are like a persistence format that
is safer than pickle so there's a bunch
of stuff add it and of course you can
also combine all of those techniques so
you can have Psy pipeline in a GD search
red tokenizers and Transformers made
faster with accelerate and more
efficient with PFT so all of that works
together so here are some links as
especially the last one for the slides
and yeah thanks everyone for listening
and yeah I take
[Applause]
questions